your argument is lacking in all
scientific merit show opens up on
Sheldon to reading one of the guys for
how dumb they are compared to himself
cliche it is well established Superman
cleans his uniform and it's all about
the comic books cliche which is worse
obvious product placement or obvious
product placement of wouldn't answer it
doesn't matter cine drops the ding
hammer down on both I think we can
safely assume that all Kryptonian
condiments were destroyed when the
planet Krypton exploded maybe but I'll
bet there's still a Kryptonian Twinkie
or two out there those things are an
absolute pain to get rid of it's
basically the herpes of the Kryptonian
snack aisle kandorian dry cl' I give up
you gon have a rational argument with
this planet see being pedantic is
hilarious
nitpicking movies is fun millions of
Nielsen households can't be wrong all at
once now Sheldon why did Sheldon stand
up he has the exact same view Howard
does doesn't do anything for me if I was
gonna go that way I'm more of a Zac
Efron kind of guy like you have a shot
with Zac Efron really thought that was
going to get into cringer territory with
this shows an ability to dodge the
homophobic joke stratosphere of the Arts
Raj nips it in the bud with reasonable
grace but you've got a better chance
hitting it with Zac Efron and getting me
to take a sin off here yeah dr.
gablehauser said if i wanted to set
something up in the photomultiplier lab
that you'd be able to give me a hand you
want to work with me actually he just
asked you to set something up for him
Leonard reads way too much into a simple
request but still somehow manages to get
women like Joyce and Penny to sleep with
him not sure what those two things have
to do with each other but seem like as
good a time as any to say Leonard aside
from this using talcum powder for Wii
bowling joke not being funny it also
feels wrong for the character he's
fastidious and technologically astute
and what world does he a think this
would help and B not freak out about the
particles gumming up the Wiimote please
do overs when my people play sports
Sandy Koufax Bill Goldberg and Dora
Torrez all just randomly scream goo
Howard with no knowledge as to why or
what for except the universe needed them
to it's just a video game and we suck at
it nice motivational speech from the
team captain art Howard and Sheldon
playing against each other though how is
this a team dynamic if that's the case
we're in a rock band
we play rock band on our Xbox nice
motivational speech from our lead
guitarist
oh so it's a running joke well if I'd
known that I would have probably taken
that ax to consider that Charlie Brown
is what boredom is all about Charlie
Brown and what Charlie Brown special
doesn't adult speak like a lesson to
Charlie Brown and what Charlie Brown
special or the adults even
comprehensible humans who don't speak
trombone you haven't given me a gift
you've given me an obligation
unprotected sex this is not a real Adam
indoorsy and pale
that's physicist it's just I don't know
how you live next door to that without
doing something about it
and I don't know how anybody watched the
show even at the time and thought that
line was worth laughing at instead of
just creepy as hell and Sheldon heard
Leonard's slight tap on the door how
exactly did he have prior knowledge that
this rather unfunny bit could unfold
right in front of him was he reading
Edgar Allen Poe's the Raven and thought
he was hearing a visitor tapping and his
chamber door is this show funny
Sheldon asked for a ride to the mall on
Wii bowling night but this is at least a
day or two later because Leonard has
already hung out with Dave again and had
his motorcycle accident and Sheldon was
home then man yes I guess they could
have set up a different day to go to the
mall because they couldn't go that
evening but I didn't see it I hate this
show I'm also a dick time Sinha - oh
good kidding you've got lotions and bath
oils and soaps that's the estrogen hat
trick
I thought the estrogen hat trick was
sore breast hot flashes and being at war
with your insides every few weeks I
think what you're talking about is the
female stereotypes hat-trick easy
mistake I gave the show a lot of flack
because well it's horrible but it does
have flashes of genius including the
store which is called Lebon quotidian
which means the daily bath is a French
play on words for the French saying
lafon quote Didion meaning the daily
bread that's a long way to go for a joke
that is barely seen and almost no one
will get and if there's one thing I can
appreciate its stretching for a joke I
don't understand what you're talking
about and you're making me a little
uncomfortable
little after almost 30 episodes I've
created 876 new safe words for every new
cringy situation this show is presented
me with and I'll have to say that that
is hamster Paisley great news Leonard
I'm no Big Bang Theory historian but
even I know that Leonard's legs and feet
are all over Sheldon special couch seat
right now and he would not be having
this he kicked Kaley Cuoco out of that
seat so I'm pretty sure he's
not putting up with Leonard's taint the
toes how did none of the big band gang
not know this they certainly seem to
know a lot about the guy when they were
gossiping about him over fake colas
earlier by the way my leg is killing me
thanks for asking the show tips to have
a running joke about a lame leg and the
irony of that conceptual idea is way
funnier than any part of its actual
execution you're here to exchange gifts
but where is Leonard's original gift
when she first came over with the gift
she had to wrap presents now she has one
wrap present and an envelope sorry the
napkins dirty he wiped his mouth with it
actually you would need a mature somatic
cell that includes a nucleus with intact
chromosomes and saliva but doesn't have
that who's the nerd now nerd 101 totally
cool science experiments for kids you
know cuz you're so into science see this
is a fun callback to an offhand remark
earlier in the episode and then it comes
full circle and creates a pretty funny
joke at the end I'm not removing a sin
but I am acknowledging the potential is
there for humor in this show which makes
how unfunny the rest of the episode is
all the more irritating you recycled
this gift
he's a regifter Superman says sure works
up a sweat comes back to earth his
uniform now stained with indestructible
Kryptonian perspiration who always
do-overs when my people play sports what
do you mean you people what do you mean
you people
my first Hanukah with Sheldon he yelled
at me for eight nights instead of one
day of presents we had a crazy night my
question is what's up with that
[Music]